happy thanksgiving and to you gobble
gobble oh
nobody says that do they i think a lot
of people do they say gobble do you ever
say gobble gobble andy
not in that context
oh okay let's reset jim
this is for the family this one uh right
they're all gathered around the show
watching
um now you're here you're not home for
thanksgiving
i would i would guess your family must
be disappointed that you're from texas
i'm from texas that's right no well
they've i think they've grown accustomed
to the lack of me on thanksgiving i've
been out here and working we've
taped last night so i can't i don't fly
home immediately afterwards
right um christmas i always go home for
yes that's a that's that's a big one
have you ever missed christmas i missed
christmas once we i got snowed in
somewhere in the middle of the country i
can never remember where i was but it
was
we got snowed in and i was alone and i
spent the night in the hotel and i went
back the next day
to try and get on a flight and they
weren't starting up and they finally had
just a few de-icers i guess and they
were
doing one runway at a time and i was
living in new york and they got a flight
going out in new york that was going to
leave and i thought
i don't want to stay here anymore and so
i was like i'm going to go back home to
new york and so i called my mom and i
said listen they're letting very few
flights out
but i'm going to home to new york and
she was very quiet and
she literally said well you have ruined
christmas
i swear to god she's she said that for
swear to god you've ruined christmas i
mean you know and it was so over
dramatic that it was it was kind of nice
because now i have that and i've told
people that forever that my mother's
actually told me that i've ruined
christmas
right you know i i really think she
overdid herself and it took the guilt
away thank you
mother watching right now it's all up
from here yeah it's nice exactly now i
know that you
uh you have enormous success now like a
lot of actors you you did your time in
live theater and i did i did a lot of
life there i did a lot of live theater
in houston which was wonderful
at the university or whatever and i was
with a wonderful group uh there
and uh we it was some of the best
training because we went from
different space like in a parking lot
we'd be in a
warehouse uh and wonderful theater we
did a production of a beckett show
called endgame once and my parents
came to it and beckett can be very dour
or
sad but it's a comedy i don't know
anyway um it's odd
i'm familiar with that thank you okay
and uh my mother
specifically said to me she goes i don't
like seeing you in this condition you
know the way i was doing the play and it
was just kind of down and
she said specifically about the
warehouse we were in because this is the
kind of place you could find a dirty
needle in once again very dramatic love
your mom like
oh she's wonderful that's so specific
this is where i get the drama from and
the specificity you're absolutely right
but what was funny is i went back to do
the play the next week and i told the
director that she had said that and he
was
laughing because we did find a dirty
needle
so you know bravo mother's instincts
yeah
your mom should work for the dea exactly
she's like i know this place i know this
is not smell the heroin
[Laughter]
hmm
you can't say gobble gobble after that
it's oh what does that say in your cup
a gimbal oh i just have little nonsense
words i've had this
gibble is on there yes which is nonstop
that's why no that's not why you said
gobble gob well you said it because of
you thank you so much subliminally
affected me though i could have seen
that in the corner of my eye
all of your anecdotes are written out on
this book
you